une autre
pour moi Aya Nakamura c'est une star
elle ne peut pas faire une file
d'attente avec des gens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
retrouvés pour assister au match de
Facebook de l'underfist et retrouvailles
glacial ou les deux stars se sont
complètement
ignorés par un mot ni même un regard
mais sur cette vidéo un geste a fait le
buzz et retenu l'attention on y voit
shakira en train de se gratter l'oeil
mais qui a été interprété différemment
par les internautes bah le dos c'est
qu'il se déteste en fait il l'a trompé
avec une femme beaucoup plus jeune au
début de l'été en tout cas c'est là
qu'elle l'a appris ils ont fait leurs
vacances plein sans l'autre ils sont
séparés tout le monde là dessus ce qui
est assez impressionnant dans ce cas
précis c'est que ça a précipité la fin
de carrière de Gérard Piqué entre autres
enfin carrière de footballeur pour ceux
qui ne savent pas et Shakira oui sur ce
qui se dit c'est que c'est une haine
viscérale entre les deux que ça va être
un divorce terrible elle peut passer à
autre chose déjà j'ai horreur d'entendre
il a été trouvé par elle a été trouvé
par une femme beaucoup plus jeune on
s'en fout qu'elle soit plus jeune plus
vieille c'était surtout non mais c'était
surtout son employé donc il y a un peu
déontologie il se dit elle elle disait
voilà elle se fréquent vous savez ce
qu'on dit nos hommes insectes
quand votre mari le père de vos enfants
vous ment et vous trompe plusieurs mois
mal mal ça c'est pour l'instant on n'est
pas détendu hein pour l'instant ils font
des communications communes donc c'est
déjà pas mal elle retombe vivre aux
États-Unis avec ses enfants
en plus des vacances scolaires ça va oui
mais ça va mais bon en fait ce qui est
regrettable dans ce genre d'histoire
c'est toujours les enfants qui ont
pâtissent c'est ça qui est triste
ça c'est ça c'est sûr
[Musique]
franchement cool
une autre une autre
[Musique]
tous les gens connus et même dans ce
plateau personne fait la queue à
l'aéroports
en fait passer par là aussi parce que ça
fait des meute
pour moi Aya Nakamura c'est une star
elle ne peut pas faire une file
d'attente avec des gens c'est impossible
même pour la sécurité même pour
l'écoulement des gens c'est impossible
n'ayant Nakamura c'est comme l'équipe de
France de foot ils vont pas attendre
trois heures devant tout le monde va y
avoir des milliers de selfies c'est ça
crée une émeute tu es con de la première
la dernière minute de mission
une une des gens ils ne bloque pas des
gens pour leur faire passer elle a juste
un passage privilégié
pour toi
[Applaudissements]
aussi de particules grâce à ta notoriété
donc non tu peux pas lui en vouloir à
elle et toi tu fais la même aussi
parfois par exemple des tarifs tout ça
des prix mais encore une fois c'est au
détriment de personnes et pourquoi les
gens font la queue pourquoi tu payes
moins cher alors que tu es blindé alors
que quelqu'un qui a moins d'argent que
toi il va payer je n'enlève pas la
chambre de quelqu'un je paye moins cher
ma chambre pourquoi payer moins cher tu
négocies j'ai adoré
moins cher mais je paye moins cher parce
que alors ça c'est autre chose l'hôtel
est ravi de recevoir un artiste
allez bah oui la clientèle est heureuse
vous rentrez donc le 10 octobre
à quel moment vous comprenez qu'elle est
plus là
tout de suite je travaille je vois les
clés et son téléphone qui est posé
sur la table je suis allé dans sa
chambre et elle n'y était plus
et je suis partie directement à la
brigade de neville-sur-saône pour dire
que ma fille n'était plus là
ils ont des considérés que c'était une
fugue parce que ma fille avait déjà fait
deux fugues auparavant sauf que là c'est
pas une simple fugue ma fille est partie
sans vêtements sans vêtement sans son
téléphone sans ses clés sans rien sans
carte de bus sans argent sans doudoune
je me bats depuis 45 jours maintenant
pour dire que ma fille n'est pas enfui
et que ma fille est en danger la Brigade
de Recherche a pris le téléphone de ma
fille et à contacter snapchat en
Amérique pour avoir le droit de
retrouver tous les snaps ils font un
boulot qui est très très bien les
enquêteurs la brigade de recherche de
Lyon il y en avait déjà fugué pendant
combien de temps quatre jours pourquoi
elle avait fugué quels étaient vos
relations
a été victime
d'un viol en collectivité
assez dix ans
et que la justice française est très
longue
et Dieu personne ne l'a cru j'étais la
seule à me battre depuis
et qu'elle est vraiment pas bien
qu'elle est vraiment pas bien depuis
donc c'est des appels
quand elle part elle se met en danger
elle est en autodestruction totale au
niveau du
son les personnes qui ont commis ce viol
aujourd'hui
bien sûr ils ont ma fille elle les a
reconnu on a des photos on a tout
ce qui sont incarcérés ce qui sont ils
sont placés sous contrôle judiciaire et
ma fille depuis deux ans
psychologue psychiatre avocat police
ils n'ont rien ils sont tranquillement
chez eux alors ils sont placés sous
contrôle judiciaire ils ont interdiction
de sa prochaine mon enfant elle a fugué
une première fois pendant quatre cinq
jours vous l'avez retrouvé dans un
appartement elle était seule dans cet
appartement elle était avec combien de
personnes deux hommes de majeurs deux
hommes majeurs les connaissait avant
elle les a connu pendant sa fugue oui
d'accord donc elle les a connu pendant
sa fugue et c'est deux jeunes l'ont
recueilli
avec des coups de couteau dans les
jambes et de rouiller elle a été à
l'hôpital prise de sang d'accord
si elle nous regarde si quelqu'un l'a vu
si quelqu'un l'a reconnaît ce soir
l'émission il est 21h30 en en direct
c'est vraiment parce que Gaëlle Ludivine
et toute la famille sont extrêmement
inquiets on les comprend bien entendu le
matin de la disparition elle va à
l'école non elle est déscolarisée parce
que elle a peur du regard des donc là
vous la laissez seul à la maison j'ai
été obligée de la laisser travailler
je suis rentrée à midi pour manger avec
elle elle me dit maman s'il te plaît
reste avec moi je lui dis que je pouvais
pas qu'il fallait que je travaille
et j'y suis allé
elle a eu 13 ans elle a eu 13 ans ce
week-end le 19 novembre
ce jour-là ça a dû être terrible pour
vous vous êtes dit je vais peut-être
avoir un signe quelque chose ce jour-là
je veux même pas de mal à la personne
qui l'a retient je veux juste qu'on me
rende mon enfant
elle est avec des personnes que je leur
veux pas de mal que je porterai pas
plainte je ferai rien que je veux juste
resserrer mon bébé une dernière dans mes
bras
je suis une
aime tellement beaucoup à son petit
frère Taïs à tout le monde toute sa
famille j'ai l'impression que vous êtes
en train de vous adresser à eux que vous
sentez quelque chose vous sentez que
votre fille est si Christ et séquestré
quelque part ces personnes qu'elle a
qu'elle a croisé lors de sa première
fugue oui et vous pensez qu'elle y
retourner avec eux je pense qu'ils sont
nuls là chercher oui
qui sont venus la chercher
c'est votre sentiment parce qu'elle m'a
promis elle m'a dit que c'était l'enfer
ce qu'elle avait vécu et qu'elle voulait
plus y retourner
et vous pensez qu'ils ont retrouvé sa
trace donc chez vous ils sont venus la
kidnapper
alors justement
c'est quoi ça c'est une information
importante
sur les réseaux ils étaient venus la
chercher chez son papa et que son papa
fait en sorte de la faire sortir de la
voiture d'accord
il s'est accroché à la voiture et
et il a fait descendre enfin il a tiré
le frein à main enfin comme la détresse
d'un papa quoi normal et donc ils l'ont
laissé repartir
ils ont énormément mon ex mon
ex-conjoint ça y est une bagarre et puis
la police est venue et puis il y a eu un
ou deux hommes qui ont été arrêtés
c'est pour ça que ce qu'on comprend pas
oui Raymond c'est complètement fou parce
que ces deux personnes qui avaient déjà
séquestré ils viennent chez elle chez
son papa pour la reprendre une deuxième
fois
Marc Serrano merci on a vu qu'il Caron
voilà qui est souvent venu nous voir
propose l'interdiction des corridas vous
lui répondez quoi
c'est l'interdiction de de tout un art
de tout un rythme de toute une culture
si c'était si
peu aimé il y aurait pas des millions
d'amis qui viendraient
chaque année au feria alors c'est
Solveig je vous présente mon épouse
c'est Solveig qui est là Solveig qui est
qui nous donnera son avis dans un
instant alors Cathy il est temps
à Paris serait en prison donc vous
invitez des sociopathes il faut savoir
que monsieur est à l'extrême droite bien
sûr affiner l'extrême droite et que vous
vous avez été condamné pour pour
diffamation non pas tout ce que dit
cette dame bien évidemment je suis pas
d'accord avec elle parce que je veux pas
vous
auriez la queue les oreilles la queue
non est-ce qu'on laisse parler est-ce
qu'on laisse parler c'est toujours la
même chose avec vous vous êtes une
fasciste elle laisse parler la Solveig
elle est calme ce soir je trouve
qui qui fait l'apologie de la corrida se
vante de se branler devant les
documentaires de la Shoah c'est dans ses
livres il se vendent nos règles
les génisses contre l'eugénisme on ne
dialogue on est dialogue pas avec on est
pas avec le danger la majorité
s
moi je suis contre la corrida on a un
torero ici on a un mec qui flotte
parler pour rien
arrête de dire de faire des bêtises mais
qu'est-ce que tu me parles des taureaux
on avait le mec qui tue les taureaux il
était là tu vois ils sont partis j'ai
fini les mots il faut déjà rouges à
lèvres là c'est n'importe quoi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les mecs on va pas s'embrouiller avec
Solveig tu délires là non non non
[Applaudissements]
tais-toi mais tais-toi
tu vas Mont-de-Marsan qu'est-ce que tu
veux dire que les provinces sont des
bourrins et que la souffrance
il y a quelqu'un qui a changé les piles
[Applaudissements]
et les barbecues c'est les hommes
et la pollution
[Applaudissements]
puisque les portraits officiels des 30
sont sortis on a donc Alsace Camille
c'est dira donc ça c'est sa photo
officielle misakiten Oriane galves Soto
sa photo officielle magnifique Miss
Auvergne Alicia la DBZ Laurent Le Breton
qui est Miss Bourgogne Enora morale Miss
Bretagne attention Miss centre Val de
Loire Coraline l'oral
Miss Champagne-Ardenne
ah ah alors là soleil scors Oriane
Meloni et Flavie Barlin
[Rires]
Navarro Miss Franche-Comté
Guadeloupe Indira en Pio elle est pas à
China Robin 20 ans Miss Guyane à
pas mal mais c'est Île-de-France Adèle
Bonamour Cameron Vallières étudiante en
marketing 23 ans
Delphine
donc c'est Miss Languedoc c'est bien
alors Miss Limousin Salomé Maud Sarah
Wattara aoutar Axel René
kinésithérapeute Florence de mortier
Miss Pyrénées
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après plus de 18 ans de diffusion sur
France 3 la chaîne a diffusé la fin de
la série Plus Belle La Vie qui a
passionné des milliers de gens et des
millions de gens surtout pendant
un vrai plaisir de d'être ici très
content de te voir vraiment
on s'est connu avant d'être connu en
fait absolument exactement
aux Puces de Saint-Ouen
Plus Belle La Vie Fabienne Carat joue le
rôle de Samia Nasri une jeune femme
d'origine algérienne qui a grandi dans
une cité de Marseille elle est
principalement connue pour être
gardienne de la paix est-ce que tu
comprends la décision de France
Télévisions d'avoir arrêté Plus belle la
vie comprendre non un peu que la
respecter ou la subir
moi j'ai été épargnée parce que j'avais
déjà fait la démarche de partir deux ans
avant mais donc je l'ai pris beaucoup de
recul mais j'étais très heureuse qu'on
me propose de revenir pour la fin ça m'a
permis de d'accompagner un petit peu mes
camarades de leur montrer qu'il y avait
une vie aussi après en parallèle et puis
pour le public ça a fait un joli clin
d'oeil et ça a permis aussi de
comprendre la fin de du personnage parce
qu'on savait être un petit peu précipité
tu te rappelles la première apparition
elle est grave il aurait pu prévenir
on peut savoir qui vous êtes parce que
vous rentrez chez les gens sans prévenir
je suis la sœur du mec habité ici un
autre truc aussi c'est la prochaine
soirée de Daniel Moreau puisqu'ils ont
anticipé
à une heure de grande écoute la série
avait aussi montré les débuts d'un plan
à trois
entre Marine la surveillance du lycée
Stéphane prieur et l'infirmier voilà et
c'est vrai que
les voix inali à tour de rôle du poppers
on se rappelle on l'avait passé ici ça
voilà et c'est vrai que tout le monde au
moins Plus belle la vie ça faisait
parler moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la série est enfin continuez avec les
réseaux sociaux est-ce que ça a modifié
à votre avis votre manière d'incarner
les personnages l'écriture les thèmes
les polémiques et tout ça avec les
réseaux sociaux on a un retour direct
quand il y a une intrigue qui bouscule
ou le personnage qui fait quelque chose
qui ne plaît pas au public on a des
commentaires dans un sens ou dans
l'autre et forcément là oui il y a un
retour direct qu'on n'avait pas au tout
début au début on attend on avait juste
un rapport dans la rue les gens ça
retrouve dans la rue mais là sur les
réseaux sociaux ça peut être plus
violent parce que bien sûr les gens sont
couverts on le sait donc oui ça change
un petit peu à ce niveau là mais il y a
aussi beaucoup comme disait Lola
beaucoup beaucoup de messages très
gentil
Plus belle la vie donc c'est fini
Fabienne toi tu as un nouveau single qui
arrive désolé et tu sens tourner à
partir de 2023 avec ton spectacle ni de
trop connu oui voilà oui parce que j'ai
voulu mettre en lumière cette cette
impasse administrative ou quand le papa
n'est pas prêt à déclarer son enfant
il faut cocher un inconnu pourquoi c'est
quoi c'est ton histoire
enfin le papa le géniteur pardon donc je
j'ai dû cocher la case inconnue père
inconnue plusieurs fois je trouve ça
très cruel et très dur pour moi déjà je
suis la maman bon ma petite fille ne mon
enfant ne comprend pas encore mais je
trouve ça dur il y a pas de il y a pas
d'alternative en fait moi je sais qui
c'est le papa donc je pense aussi et je
vais vous donner son nom
ah non mais je trouve ça bizarre en fait
quand la personne n'est pas prête pas il
est pas autre chose quoi bon voilà on
retrouvera peut-être des solutions mais
en tout cas l'administration il n'y a
pas pensé encore bah écoute pas bien en
tout cas tu sais que quand tu veux pour
moi pour me raconter ta vie pour moi
parce que Fabienne très drôle dans une
soirée elle m'a raconté sa vie j'ai
adoré c'est vrai oui merci Fabienne en
tout cas merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]